all the odds I mean he you know Rafael
comes in a different way I mean having
been you know he's in mighty grad you
know that's like very cerebral and he
has this phenomenal eye for talent I
mean I remember one of the first times
we met for a drink he looks at this girl
across the room his playing piano and he
goes that girl is a she is an actress I
go how do you know that he goes oh she's
not yet but she will be and she became a
star right what's that girl's name is
Joe glacier and I mean she's an
obviously great piano player it was at
the Beverly Wilshire and it was so funny
cuz she Rafael was like looking at her
but not the way a man looks at a cute
girl but looking at her like realizing
she was untacked but that she it was um
it was like spooky and then she emerged
yeah and he's done we get a fun was
really his movie it was unrewarded
because it was it was ahead of its time
in terms of the decadent girl teenager
nihilistic depraved mentality and he
poor performances out on these girls he
just sees the girls I don't know where
comes from because you know I've met a
lot of people from MIT and they're
usually really really rigid thinkers you
know because engineering and that kind
of thing is pretty rigid so that's what
I would say to people you have to need
to do it because it makes no sense maybe
it's because my a female is my alter ego
I don't know and maybe I've never grown
up look I love these young characters
who are just learning and groping and
searching and trying to figure it out
because I guess that's what I'm still
trying to do I still have it figured it
out I'm working on it what did people
tell you about fun in the beginning
because they're very extreme characters
I watched the trailer this morning and
I'd like to see the film and was it
scary for people to see females in those
roles like even though you knew their
backstory I'm sure probably with yeah
yeah I think it was pretty shocking you
know I think people are very disturbed
by the film it was also based on a very
stink play there was very multicolored
you know where there was no good or evil
it's presented a case where two girls
were very abused very difficult
situation you know they met for one day
and they did this horrific act of
killing for random killing which is very
much similar to what's going on with
these shootings today basically it's
very relevant but it shows that this was
a sort of an exorcism citizen for them a
cleansing of all the only hell that was
you know thrown on them so in a way it
was a release so then what is the good
and the bad in that who is the you know
who is responsible was it the parent is
it society is it games you know the
violence in the media what is it and it
you know those were the interesting
themes and I think those things are
still here we're still working on them
more and more actually
you